monor was there in San
Francisco when the whole city was coming
down these guys were taking pictures
like they'd been waiting for
it you think that your father was
working for them this stuff wasn't as
safe why they what's
Monarch there's a new one coming
this is the world we live in monsters
are an inescapable reality and
it's those files belong to us and they
are more important than you could
possibly
imagine this is going to give me
nightmares now you can choke down that
Monarch
lie about your father disappearing
with or we can find out what really
happened before it's too
[Music]
late oh my God go go go this world it's
not ours believe
me is so much more vast than we could
possibly imagine
these monsters and Monarch have taken
everything from
me no
more the world is on fire if you want to
save millions of lives we can use some
help
re
new
come